[Music]
I'm inconvenient for the future of the
planet
I'm inconvenient because I love my
mother mother earth the poorest of the
poor are furious because they're hit
first and worst by climate change we
can't do this alone we have to do this
together we have one planet we live on
we don't Rianne tall Mars yet so until
we get there I'm inconvenient
I'm inconvenient because I care about
the planet
I'm inconvenient for my still growing
family it's our responsibility to be
inconvenient for future generations
I'm inconvenient because more often than
not doing the right thing is not always
the most convenient thing I'm
inconvenient because it's our
responsibility to take care of our
planet
I'm inconvenient because I still believe
that something can it has to be done for
our future generations
I'm inconvenient for my children's
children we are inconvenient for the
future of our planet
I am inconvenient because we only have
one planet and we have to do all that we
can to keep her healthy it's really
important that we continue to engage
each other and remind each other the
importance of renewable energy and again
hold our local politicians accountable
[Music]
it's supposed to be 70 degrees today at
free secure speaking of global warming
where is we need some global warming
it's freezing the most criticized scene
in the movie An Inconvenient Truth was
showing that the combination of sea
level rise and storm surge would flood
the 9/11 memorial site and people said
what a terrible exaggeration hurricane
sandy slammed into New York City last
night plotting the World Trade Center
site storms get stronger and more
destructive watch the water splash off
the city this is global warming through
scared despair can be paralyzing but
this to me is the most exciting new
development we're seeing a tremendous
amount of positive change the basis is
there but it's still not enough
it's crunch time had a climate change
conference in Paris just some really
tough negotiations going on what would
it take the shift to renewables I'm
talking about breaking the impasse
virtually every nation in the entire
world agreed to get to zero greenhouse
emissions it is unprecedented it's time
to put America first that includes a
promise to cancel billions in climate
change spending our plan will end the
EPA
the next generation would be justified
in looking back at us and asking what
were you thinking couldn't you hear what
the scientists were saying couldn't you
hear what Mother Nature was screaming at
you
this movement is in the tradition of
every great movement that has advanced
humankind
[Music]
we're not going to recognize it we don't
want to discuss it
[Music]
it is right to save humanity it is wrong
to pollute this earth it is right to
give hope to the future generation
don't let anybody tell you that we're
gonna get on rocket ships and live on
Mars this is our home
[Music]
you
you
[Music]